so there's a debate raging in Congress
right now about whether Congress should
get a pay raise a $4,500 pay raised to
be exact or as it's being called a
cost-of-living increase you know it's
not a pay raise it's a cost-of-living
increase yes it's a it's a it is a raise
in pay but it's that's not what it is
just cost-of-living because you see
Congress has not gotten a rate or excuse
me a cost cost-of-living increase in a
decade and now apparently they think
they think they're due for one although
some members of Congress are concerned
that'll be politically disastrous to be
seen you know for them to be seen giving
themselves more money especially when
their approval ratings are so low so
there's kind of a game being played out
right now where a game where politicians
who are sort of safer politically are
advocating for the raise and those who
are in a more precarious position
politically are pretending to be against
it but of course at the end of the day
they all want to have more money one of
the people advocating for the raise is
the lovely Alexandria al kzo Cortes and
her argument for her own raise is really
I mean it's it's really pretty awful so
listen to this you know it may not be
politically popular to say but honestly
this is why there's so much pressure to
turn to lobbying firms and to cash in on
on members service after people leave
because
because precisely up of this issue so it
may be politically convenient and it may
make you look good in the short term for
saying oh we're not voting for pay
increases but we should be fighting for
pay increases for every American worker
you should be fighting for a $15 minimum
wage pegged to inflation so that
everybody in the United States with a
salary with with the wage gets a
cost-of-living increase members of
Congress retail workers everybody should
get cost-of-living increases to
accommodate for the changes in our
economy and then when we don't do that
it only increases the pressure on
members to exploit loopholes like
insider trading loopholes to make it on
the background so first of all you see
what she's doing here right she's she's
whining for a raise but she's
positioning it as an act of courage on
her part she's saying hey it may not be
politically convenient to say this okay
I know a lot of people don't have the
guts to say this but I should get more
money you know
listen it's easy for someone to say
don't give me money but I'm standing
here saying give me money okay
I've got the guts to say it um that's a
that's an interesting it's an
interesting strategy second she says
that if you don't give us a raise
we're gonna be corrupt and we'll end up
finding other ways to make money we're
gonna look for you know we're gonna make
deals with lobbyists and we're gonna
find loopholes and all the stuff
what kind of argument is that can you
can could you ever use that at work okay
if you're working at Burger King could
you go up to your to your manager and
say hey boss give me money or I'm gonna
start stealing from the register all
right it's your choice
okay this is it's up to you balls in
your court champ I mean if you can give
me money or I can steal from the
register I'll be but either way so
really if you don't give me money and I
steal the register it's your fault
that's a you you forced my hand so
that's the way it's gonna be um no
that's see that's the that's only an
argument that's the kind of argument
that you could only find in the halls of
Congress it doesn't work anywhere else
in the actual working world I've got an
idea though here's an alternative maybe
the
people can just make do with the paltry
174 thousand dollars a year that they're
already paid that's a good salary that's
like 3 times the national average
should our representatives really be
paid more than three times what the
average citizen makes should they make
even that much when a when a
representative on the you know
rare occasion that a representative
leaves DC and actually comes home to
their own district and they hold a town
hall or something what few even do that
anymore but should and they're
surrounded by their constituents at this
town hall should they be the
highest-paid person in the room
conceivably you know in the year 1815
members of Congress were paid the
equivalent of twenty thousand dollars a
year in today's money in 1795 they made
one dollar a day and of course that
means they weren't paid anything on the
days when they weren't in session it was
a part-time job so when you say well how
do they survive on that they didn't
survive on that they had other jobs they
did other things this was not a career
it wasn't something that you were
supposed to you know settle down and
spend 50 years doing aoc says that
lowers our salaries lead to more
corruption but is that real is there
evidence of that is that really how we
see the trends working because salaries
for members of Congress went up
dramatically into the 20th century and
the 21st century as well and I don't see
any evidence that corruption went down
in the meantime now I'm not saying there
wasn't corruption in in in 1815 of
course there was but is there evidence
that there was more back then than there
is now with lower salaries I don't think
if anything it seems that the trend
works in the opposite direction and why
is that well because if someone is
inclined to be a money-grubbing greedy
selfish dishonest charlatan you aren't
gonna say she ate them with a higher
salary okay if someone is a morally
corrupt individual you aren't gonna
solve that problem by giving them more
it just doesn't it doesn't work that way
just like going back to the Burger King
example if someone isn't if someone's a
thief and they're inclined to steal even
if you raise their salary to $15 an hour
they're probably still gonna steal
because they're our thief if anything
what happens is when you give them more
money you only whet their appetite
that's the way that it works with with
thieves and and higher salaries are more
likely to attract those kinds of people
in the first place if congressmen were
paid let's say $40,000 a year most
likely the selfish money grubbers
wouldn't run in the first place now they
might some of them still might but but I
think that there's a higher likelihood
that the selfish money-grubbing types
would not be inclined to run in the
first place because of the lower salary
and because it's less money practically
speaking but also because with a lower
salary I think it it takes away some of
the some of the esteem some of the clout
that you get from being a member of Chi
if everyone knew that these people are
paid $40,000 a year and so they're you
know basically just based on that salary
they're you know they're middle class
really kind of lower middle class people
based on their salary if that's how we
started to see Congress which and
there's nothing wrong with being middle
class but if that's how we started to
see them then the people who are after
money and clout which I think accounts
for probably 95% and people who run for
Congress these days I think those people
are more likely to go somewhere else I
think in that case you would end up with
two types of people running you would
have people who are already wealthy thus
they don't need the salary and then you
had a people who actually are interested
in doing public service for the sake of
public service people who will either
make do with the 40 grand a year or will
work another job and just to some
at the same time you would also find
that people are less inclined to stay in
the job for 40 or 50 years and that
would be a good thing so here's my
here's my recommendation Congress should
I think right now take a $100,000 pay
cut and then that would leave them with
74 thousand dollars a year which is
still a good salary that's that's double
the national average which i think is
very generous considering Congress's
approval rating right now is about is it
as at about 20 percent
it hasn't been above 30 in a decade it
hasn't been at 50 in almost 20 years now
do you think you'd get a raise at your
job if your boss is rated your
performance at 20 percent if you went in
for a performance evaluation and they
gave you a 20 percent do you think you'd
be in line for a raise
no you would probably be fired but at a
minimum you'd be looking at a pay cut so
that's my thought it's $100,000 pay cut
for all members of Congress if some of
them quit because of it great that's
fantastic I think I'd be wonderful if
they cry and whine because of it great
I think there's it's great to see
politicians crying I'm a big fan of that
it's a very it's you know I think it's
very American to take pleasure in the
discomfort of politicians and then I
think we we leave it at that and then
once Congress's approval rating makes it
above 50% then we could talk about a
race that should be the law that should
be the rule that you can only even
consider a raise once your approval
rating gets above 50% considering it's
been as I said about almost 20 years I
think 2002 was the last time since I had
a reproval rating that high since it's
been almost 20 years I think it it you
know they've got a lot of work to do
before they get back to 50 percent but
but that's the way it should be they
should be doing some work Congress right
now is utterly dysfunctional just cannot
do anything cannot achieve anything and
even the most basic things they can't do
so their payout to reflect that the way
this country was set up and when we call
them public servants right that's what
they're supposed to be and and you know
we always say well we're the boss you
know and they'll they'll pretend to
believe that - those are the American
people are my boss well can you imagine
if we actually lived in a country where
it really worked that way well that's
not just something we say but that's
actually how it worked that these people
really were public servants and that we
really were their bosses well it's
something uh nice to dream about in any
case all right let's slight in the mood
a little bit this is a well Justin
Trudeau one of the great minds of our
time he was talking recently about what
he does to save the environment fact he
was asked by I guess by a reporter what
he and his family what they're doing
specifically on a personal level to help
save the environment and I thought that
his answer was and again I say this as
someone who's not usually a Trudeau fan
but I thought his answer was deeply
deeply profound listen listen to this do
you and your family do to cut back on
plastics we we have recently switched to
drinking water bottles out of water out
of when we have water bottles out of a
plastic sorry away from plastic towards
paper like drink box water bottles sort
of things there's there's a number okay
here's the transcript of that if you
didn't catch it here's what his in his
answer I transcribed it just so that
this could live on as one of the great
things ever said he said we we we have
we have recently switched to drinking
water bottles out of water out of when
we have water bottles out of plastic
sorry away from plastic -
paper-like drink box water bottles I
don't mean to live I use I'm laughing
well I'm giddy with I'm just so taken by
the the profundity of this and the
eloquence of its I'm blown away just
incredible I mean I can see how this man
has had the political success he's had
someone as smart as this how could he
not by the way one other clip I wanted
to play for you you may hear today that
especially if you're on social media
which I don't know why you would be at
this point kind of a waste of time but
if you are you'll hear that there's a
scandal involving Tim Allen because Toy
Story 4 is coming out and Tim Al of
course Buzz Lightyear so he's on the
doing the press junket doing the press
tour for them for the movie and what
you're gonna hear is that Tim Allen's
racist there's a racism scandal brewing
about Tim Allen and those racism claims
apparently were sparked by a disturbing
video that of an answer that he gave on
doing one of his press interviews and
this is very disturbing I warned you but
but watch this huge pose so I won't play
a little game but if you have a black
card ok guys both have black card okay
you're playing spades
you got four in a possible your partner
says he got four in the possible the
guys you've been playing with death been
talking crap the whole game what do you
do do you bid nine I do you bid ten go
Will's and go all out for ten I've been
working Vegas 30 years I don't gamble
necessarily money involved in space I
throw deep baby go deep I don't know
what you're talking about I don't have
any idea what you just said you don't
know how to play spades I'm gonna say I
do just cuz I want to move now when I
was in Oakland California they all play
whist it's like you see the members of
Pam checking a cup of coffee
poop kids were playing whist man yes you
see Tim Allen doesn't know how to play
the game spades and this makes him
racist
apparently
how does it make him racist I mean I
look I I don't know which I guess means
I'm racist I mean I'm so racist
apparently that I didn't even know that
spades was a game associated with black
culture I mean I've played spades I
thought it was just a card game I didn't
know that it was a I didn't know that
there was any real racial dynamic to
spades
personally I prefer hearts I think
hearts is a better game I think it's
probably racist for me to say that I
guess so I this is new to me I didn't
know that there was any so and I think a
lot of people are in this in this boat
but the thing is if you're surprised to
find out that it's racist not to like
spades then that just makes you
extremely I mean you're basically in the
Klan and it's one thing not to like
spades but to not even know that you're
supposed to like spades I mean you are
the Grand drag what is it the Grand
Wizard of who's the head of the KKK
Grand Wizard granted the dragon wizard
you are the dragon wizard of the Klan
basically if you didn't know that you're
supposed to like spades so how dare you
how dare all of us all right before we
get the emails this is one other thing I
wanted to talk about this is kind of
interesting reading now from CNBC an
article on CNBC it says the me2 and
times up movement have brought huge
attention to the challenges that women
face at work but a new survey finds that
60% of male managers say they're
uncomfortable participating in regular
work activities with women including
mentoring working one-on-one or
socializing according to the survey
released by llenan org and Survey Monkey
that that's a 33 percent increase from
last year senior level men also say
they're 12 times more likely to be
hesitant about one-on-one meetings with
a junior woman than they are a junior
man 9 times more likely to be hesitant
to travel with a junior woman for work
than a junior man and six times more
likely to be hesitant to have a work
dinner with a junior woman than a junior
man Lina Norg founder and Facebook CEO
Oh Sheryl Sandberg calls the results
totally unacceptable first of all how do
you rate I never understand what these
surveys so the men say they're 12 times
more likely to be hesitant about this
or 19 how do you rate your likelihood of
doing something with that specificity I
am seven point six times more likely I
don't know how you do that but anyway
Sandburg says that it's totally
unacceptable okay Cheryl you think it's
unacceptable that's great but I would
say it's totally unacceptable to just
disregard what 60% of people in a
position are telling you I mean is that
how you operate in as a manager yourself
at Facebook probably is but if 60% of
your subordinates or reporting that they
feel a certain way about their work
environment would you conclude that
their perspective is unacceptable or
would you maybe consider the possibility
that the environment is unacceptable
what if what if 60% of women reported
that they were uncomfortable with male
mentorship well then the reaction would
be see this is why we have the me to
movement clearly there's something wrong
with men but when 60% of men are
uncomfortable it's still see this is why
we have the mewtwo movement clearly
there's something wrong with men the
problem is do you see how we what we end
up with is a lose-lose situation for men
and can you see how that might make men
uncomfortable when they know that they
lose either way the problem is that we
have expanded the word sexism to include
almost anything and we have to
the word harassment to include almost
anything we have expanded the words rape
and assault to include almost anything
and the defining factor for all of those
words is how the woman feels about it
okay if she feels that it was sexism or
harassment than it was that woman who
consensually hooked up with Aziz Ansari
but afterwards felt like it was assault
well that we say okay so it was because
afterwards she felt like it so it was so
you see the problem here a man has no
way of knowing how the woman is feeling
at the time or how she might feel later
if she doesn't say it the only way she
can really know for sure is if she tells
him but if she won't say anything if she
won't say for instance this conversation
is making me uncomfortable
or I'm uncomfortable doing this with you
I want to leave if she won't say that
then he's not going to know now unless
it's something that's clearly wrong or
inappropriate okay well if that's the
case that he should know if it is if
it's in the workplace and it's clearly a
you know an r-rated conversation just
totally inappropriate for the workplace
or for anywhere really then yeah he
should know no one should have to tell
him and there are people men and women
who just have no and I I always marvel
at these people who have no just social
awareness whatsoever they appear to just
they could make everyone around them
extremely uncomfortable and they have
did the parents are totally oblivious to
it I don't understand it because I'm
someone who's I'm sort of the opposite
I'm very hyper aware of how everyone you
know the sort of the vibe in the room I
become very aware of that probably too
aware so it's hard for me to understand
people on the other side of that
spectrum but that's men and women can be
that way so in that situation sure you
know you shouldn't need to be told but
if it's something that is arguably more
innocuous or if it's something where the
woman appears to be going
along with it whether it's a
conversation or you know as with Aziz
Ansari you know a consensual sexual
encounter you know if it's something
where the woman it appears to be
participating then there's no way for
anyone to know what's going on in her
mind and how she really feels unless she
says something yet under the new rules
she can say nothing and go along with it
and participate and appeared to be a in
accepting and enthusiastic participant
but then later on complain about it and
get him fired or worse those are the new
rules and so you're surprised that male
managers don't want to be around women
one-on-one of course they don't that's
the point we're at now with all this
stuff that it's just if you're if you
were in a position of authority as a man
it is it would be it's it's suicidal for
you to be around a woman in a work
environment one on one you should you
just should never should be there should
always be another person in the room and
the feminists can laugh at that all they
want and I'll also judge men just being
paranoid
it's hard for me not to include to
conclude I talked me not to conclude
that the reason why feminists laugh at
those kinds of precautions is because
they want men to put themselves in those
precarious positions so that they can
then be you know accused and blamed and
everything it's hard for me not to
conclude that because otherwise I mean
no matter how you feel about the me to
movement
times up whatever matter how you feel
about it wouldn't you celebrate this I
mean if or I should say if you're if
you're a feminist and you think there is
some huge epidemic of harassment and so
on and in the workplace well now you're
hearing that men you know they always
want to have another person around
they're being hyper hyper aware and very
very careful isn't that what you want
should you be
with that why would that make you angry
doesn't make any sense to me
now me I'm not happy about it but it's
just the way it is and as I said I you
know if I were a male manager I would be
the same I'd be taking the exact same
precautions it's just not worth it and
the other aspect of this is remember the
remember the slogan believe all women
right believe women believe women well
again if that's the slogan to believe
women just blanket statement just
believe that whatever they say believe
it because it's a woman well can you
really not understand how that might
make a man feel a little bit worried and
uncomfortable when he knows ahead of
time that if there's any dispute if
there's you know if anything goes
sideways
everyone's gonna believe the other
person and not him automatically no
matter who's telling the truth can you
really not understand how that might
make men feel uncomfortable is it is it
really mysterious I don't think it
should be alright let's go to emails
Matt well show at gmail.com Matt Walsh
Oh a gmail comas email address this is
from Adam says I mostly agree with your
three arguments against euthanasia
however there is an argument made in
favor of euthanasia that I find
compelling we euthanize our pets out of
compassion to eliminate their suffering
why not our human loved ones seeing a
dog or cat suffer is hard seeing a
person suffers hard like and
veterinarians put down pets when
physicians can't put down people
well Adam we spay and neuter our pets
right we don't do that to humans we feed
our pets out of bowls on the floor we
don't do that to humans generally we
lock dot we lock dog dogs in cages at
night we don't do that with we don't do
that with our kids we put them in beds I
guess some people let their dogs sleep
in bed with them I you know I find that
to be gross personally I mean why would
you want your do you know if you do that
your I don't wanna get side
you let your dog sleeping by with you
you do understand that your bed will
smell like dog and then therefore you
will smell like dog all the time you do
understand that right I mean you just I
know you don't smell it but you will
smell like dog always all the time and
everyone will smell it and they won't
tell you that you smell like dog but but
they'll think it so why would you want
that in your life that's what I don't
understand anyway so we don't generally
we you know we don't do that with with
with we do that with animals not humans
the point is we treat animals like
animals or at least we should and I
think euthanizing is part of that in
fact that's that's one of the main
reasons why I'm against euthanizing
people is because it treats a human
being like a dog who we just put down so
at a certain point with a dog or a cat
or any other horse or whatever at a
certain point if they're in a lot of
physical pain and they're in mobile and
all of that stuff we will essentially
say well there's no point to this
existence anymore there's no point to
this being living and so we might as
well just put it out of its misery and I
think with an animal that's a logical
and compassionate thing to do but I
think with people you know I think we
treat people with more dignity so when
we when we refrain from putting down
people from euthanizing people it's not
that we're treating them with less
dignity it's more it's a transcendent
that you know our treatment of other
people transcends our treatment of
animals or again at least it should and
that's the whole point so with a human
life we at least within
and human life we shouldn't reach a
point where we say well there's no point
to this existence anymore
you might as well just put them out of
their misery because human life
transcends those kinds of judgments
there is always a point to existence to
living as long as God has allowed you to
continue and for the other side of that
perspective this is from Lindsey says
dear Matt in response to your listener
who asked about euthanasia on Tuesdays
episode I'm a strongly pro-life critical
care doctor many patients with terminal
cancer spend their last days in the
intensive care unit going through a
terrible ordeal I work hand in hand with
an outstanding group of palliative care
physicians and many of them are
horrified by the perverse euthanasia
practices you know in in other countries
this is intended to make your remaining
time comfortable they do not believe in
just putting someone out of their misery
the medications and treatments given to
alleviate pain are deadly when given in
lethal doses just slugging a lethal dose
of opioids opioids at someone is
horrifying unethical and the antithesis
of compassion being pro-life in this
regard is simple when you recognize that
euthanasia for a terminal condition is a
fundamental misunderstanding of medical
capabilities and yeah I think it's very
well put Lindsey and I'm glad to hear it
from a doctor and that was my whole
point that a doctors the goal of it at
the point of medicine the point of a
doctor is to alleviate suffering and to
protect life those two things together
not separate those aren't mutually
exclusive
and I think we want our doctors and we
want people go to medical school and
enter into that profession we want them
to always be sort of pointed in that
direction we want them to look at every
situation anytime someone comes in with
any illness or sickness no matter how
severe we want our doctors always to be
thinking how can i alleviate this person
suffering while at the same time
preserving and protecting their life
that should always be the goal
of course but you're gonna reach a point
where you know the person dies and you
can't stop that so notice I'm saying
preserve and protect life that does it's
not the same thing as as saying well the
goal of a doctor should always be to
extend a life at any cost using any
method for as long as possible because
no I don't think that I mean you can
reach a point where someone would die if
not for extraordinary means that are
used just to keep them around and I
don't think that we're called always to
employ extraordinary means indefinitely
just to keep someone alive I mean there
is a certain point where it's just
someone's time to go we all have to die
and no one wants to but we all have to
and certainly none of us want our loved
ones to die but there's a point where
it's just it's it's time and no matter
what no matter how we feel about it of
course we feel terrible about it
so I don't think that's it's not the
same thing there is a point where a
doctor might say okay we have to let
this patient go and that is the most
merciful thing to do for them but there
is never a point where a doctor should
say we should kill this patient and
those are two different things
all right um this is from Justin says
hey Matt first of all thanks for all you
do I've been listening to your show for
the past few months and I admire your
sense of sarcasm and humor and dealing
with serious issues as well as your
frankness
I live in Alberta Canada where we
recently Mota Dan in a conservative
provincial government to replace a
socialist provincial government when the
old government was in they made a law
that prohibited schoolteachers from
telling parents if their kids were in a
GSA which is a Gay Straight Alliance
basically a safe space for LGBTQ MN and
LP people this was to protect students
in the alliances from any consequences
they may or may not receive at home the
new Conservative government has changed
the law to allow teachers the option to
tell parents if they feel like it's a
safe thing to say I feel that it is a
right as a parent and a tax payer to
know what my kid is doing at school some
people think it's the right of students
to not have to share that information
with their parents
which I guess is freedom of speech is it
possible that these two rights infringed
on each other making a conundrum or am I
mistaken to think that these are both
rights I realized that our
constitutional rights are different up
here in the great white north but any
thoughts or clarification would be
appreciated
PS I hope your Achilles heels quickly
prayers for you and your family and the
bees thanks Justin I assume this is not
Trudeau I'm talking to here because that
was way too coherent and rational to be
Trudeau I think that this isn't really
about this isn't really about the free
speech or privacy of the students versus
parental rights I think that's kind of a
false dichotomy I don't think you're
talking about competing rights are these
rights and competition I don't think
they are because that's not really what
we're dealing with here I think the crux
of it is this that the schools know
right the schools know what clubs the
kids are involved in so it's not some
private piece of information and then
the real question is is there anything
about your child that the schools have a
right to know but you don't should there
be any details about your child's life
that any faculty member at school knows
or could know but is unknown to you I
think the answer is obviously no so this
really it's not it's got nothing to do
with free speech or press certainly
doesn't anything do with privacy because
being involved in a club at school is
not a private matter that's a public
matter clubs at schools are not private
these aren't secret clubs okay everyone
knows who's in the club so it's not a
privacy thing I don't see how it's a
speech thing at all
it's really about who who should sort of
know the most about a child the parent
or the school now you said it right
there you said protect kids from their
parents and that was the idea behind
apparently the law in Alberta is saying
you know originally saying don't we're
not
tella pair because we're gonna protect
the kids from their parents I agree that
there are some kids who do need to be
protected from their parents but those
are parents who are actually abusive and
unfit and should be in prison okay if
there's any child out there who really
needs to be protected from their parent
that's a parent who should be in jail as
a general rule though schools should not
be generally as a blanket policy
protecting kids from their parents
that's not the way it should go
schools should not be coming in between
kids and their parents schools should
not be trying to take over the role of
the parent and I think that's what this
is really about it seems to me this is
really about schools wanting to have the
role of the parent wanting to know
things about the student that the parent
doesn't know wanting to have the upper
hand over the parent and that is I mean
that is that is a really significant
piece of information that what the
schools think they should know and the
parents shouldn't I mean just think
about that they're good the schools
should know more about your child's
sexual orientation than you do the kids
first period you know social studies
teachers should know more about that
than you as the pets gets crazy omits
it's insane and you know it's just more
reason for me in my opinion to if you
can to get the kids out of the public
school system this is from a book a
holic anonymous dropout says dear
crippled Matt frustrated book holux
across the nation are spending hours and
hours trying to figure out what the
books are on your shelf
would you please relieve our misery and
tell us the titles of the books a
close-up of the bookshelf would work but
I might recommend you remove what looks
like a bottle of cough syrup first well
legend has it that I I did a show a
little while ago where the focus was off
on my camera so that I'm not in focus
but my bookshelf is in focus and as the
story goes the reason why
happen is because I'm an idiot who
doesn't know how to work a camera and
and and that's why that happened I don't
know you know it's I can't I can neither
confirm nor deny these stories but you
could go searching for that footage and
then if you found it you could see the
bookshelf in all of its glory and all of
the titles very crystal clear by the way
that's not coughs here up that is holy
water all right let's do it do one who
do one more this is from Richard says
greetings great overlord and omnipotence
of the coming era of your rule as a
civil war re-enactor and military
historian I am curious if you could
share with us your top five Civil War
personalities and why in your view it is
important to not only study but remember
this epic history we all share I thought
this question timely seeing as you
mentioned you were binge reading the war
and I hope to hear your thoughts speedy
and healthy recovery thanks for all you
do so that's interesting so this caught
my eye
you said top five Civil War
personalities so you know not top five
Civil War generals or leaders you're
looking just for the most interesting
personalities I guess is what you're
looking for so that that's that's a
that's a fascinating way of looking at
it okay so in no particular order I
guess I would say well I'd put Stonewall
Jackson on the list now he would make my
list of top five generals avoid probably
be number one for me but I'd also put
him in as a top personality because I'd
find him fascinating I've read three
biographies about him
he really he seems like the kind of
person that a novelist would invent and
there are a lot that's why I love
studying the Civil Wars because there
are so many people so many events that
you read and you think that really was
that person really like that that really
happened it just it seems like something
someone would invent it seems like a
story that someone made up but of course
it's real I mean this this really
happened so Stonewall Jackson he is this
kind of odd nerdy soft-spoken guy who
all the students at VMI where he was a
professor before the war all the
students were to make fun of them and
don't take him very seriously tend to
laugh at him and tease him and then the
Civil War comes around
hands up commanding troops and he
reveals himself to be this brilliant
hard-nosed
still eccentric yet brave leader of men
you know he just he was someone who was
just sort of born for that moment and
became this great leader once the war
started probably my favorite anecdote
about Stonewall Jackson is from his
deathbed kind of famous I you know
certainly if you've studied the war you
already know this but after he was shot
by his own men at the Battle of
Chancellorsville accidentally you know
friendly fire accident and then he's
recovering and gets pneumonia and now
he's dying in pneumonia and it's a
Sunday you know he's at death's door on
a Sunday it's a week but a week after he
sustained the the wound originally and
the surgeon comes in and Stonewall says
doctor my wife tells me that I'm gonna
die today is that true the doctor says
yes so I'm afraid so
and he says good good I've always wanted
to die on a Sunday then I just I find
that to be I don't I just you find that
a lot in the Civil War just these men
who were incomprehensibly brave and had
no qualms about their own death not that
they were suicidal or something but just
they put honor and patriotism and all
that so far above their own physical
safety and I really just admire that I'd
also put Abraham Lincoln on there
Lincoln is a fascinating character in
many ways I haven't studied him I don't
you know I haven't studied sort of the
political leaders as much as the
military ones in the Civil War but I
think he's another one that prior to his
election was seen as this kind of
unremarkable somewhat strange guy yet he
rose to the moment and obviously
ultimately will go down as one of the
most consequential Americans ever to
live I would put George McClellan on the
list now he of course would not make a
list of top generals but as far as top
personalities I think he's an
interesting he's interesting personality
because he's so diametrically opposed to
he's the exact opposite basically of
Stonewall Jackson Abraham Lincoln Grant
Lee he's the opposite of all them in
that he's this flamboyant arrogant guy
who got a lot of hype you know when he
was appointed to
command the art army but then when when
it came down to it and the boat started
flying he was you know he became timid
and afraid and he shrank away and he was
a huge disappointment grant as I just
mentioned I think he fits the theme of
these guys who prior to the war you
never would have expected to be great
leaders historic leaders grant was a
failure in business he was an alcoholic
but and you know in fact even when the
war started in the West even after
Shiloh even after his early victories in
the West he was still doubted by the
public doubted by his superiors yet he
would be ultimately the one to take down
robert e lee and then finally I guess I
would put Nathan Bedford Forrest I think
definitely a very flawed man he was a
slave trader before the war but someone
with no military training at all a very
little education of any kind
basically illiterate I Blair or totally
illiterate I think yet he just had this
raw talent raw military genius and
incredible bravery incredible physical
bravery which he was able to use to
torment the the Union in the West all
throughout the war his famous quote is
as I said war means fighting and
fighting means killing it was just very
simple straightforward that was his
approach and he said you know this is my
job just to kill people and so that
makes him interesting maybe not an
admirable character in many respects but
an interesting one man he was in any
event all right um and by the way I know
that media matters they like to monitor
this show and they go through it every
day to find parts of it that they can
then put on Twitter to accuse me of
being a racist or homophobic and my
prediction right now is that they're
gonna take that bit that what I just
said there about Nathan Bedford Forrest
and it's gonna do they're gonna put that
on Twitter it's really Matt admires
slave Matt Walsh admires slave trader
Matt Walsh comes out as pro-slavery so
that's my that's my Nostradamus
prediction right there hello again to
the my Media Matters fans and we'll
leave it there thanks everybody for
watch
thanks for listening Godspeed hey
everyone its Andrew Clavin host of the
Andrew Clavin show hidin Biden came out
of hiding yesterday to attack Donald
Trump and virtually everything he said
was distorted or untrue or distorted and
untrue but we know the news media will
never fact check him or question him or
even allow anyone to object to him
without the danger of being deep LAT
formed and silenced so this election is
going to be not just a battle between
Donald Trump and Biden or some other
Democrat it's going to be a fight
between reality and the Democrats
carefully constructed Empire of Lies who
win will talk about it on the Andrew
Klavan show on Andrew Cleveland